hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm gonna be
watching the trailer for qui JA Ouija
something like that anyway I'm gonna
check this trailer out I'm assuming it
has to do with the Ouija board if it
doesn't then very misleading title I
like horror movies I do get a thrill out
of them nothing like its cinematic
xscape ISM to put yourself in a feeling
of fear terror whether that be you know
killing someone or something
supernatural it's worth everything to
put those images in your mind it won't
[ __ ] you up at all I'm really depressed
let's check out this trailer olivia cook
is in it no idea who that is
wait she the chick from Bates Motel or
whatever what's going on I just want to
go out tonight you sure you don't want
to come I'm good oh go have fun
oh never feel like even after someone
you love has died there's still way you
can talk to them you want to talk to
Debbie this is where Debbie died I don't
think this is a good idea as friends
we've gathered hearts are true
Spirits near we call to you if you can
hear us
Debbie I machine coaltown it's an old
house this is a joke come on you guys
he's doing so kind of how I'm not
pushing just bolt I said hey this is
freaking me out I'm done with this I
wanted to get this on camera
in my house where things started
happening is how the guard did he found
the board in your house she woke
something else
close snap it's somebody there sting
Tonio's hello it's coming for all of us
so who's next
oh you have to break the connection
where it will keep coming for you we
have to play the game again last time
as friends we gather true
it's not even real okay just that's the
kind of movie that sounds so stupid in
me like oh my gosh a Ouija board really
how many times have we seen that used
before but I don't think I've seen a
movie where it's strictly based on like
that so that's pretty interesting just
they take it mainly just off of the game
itself I kind of freaked the [ __ ] out I
don't know why I got so scared if that
was pretty [ __ ] scary MIT's
supernatural stuff freaks me out way
more than like serial killer [ __ ] for
some reason but ya know that movie looks
[ __ ] tariffs I think Olivia Cooke is
the girl from Bates Motel or I'm getting
the actresses name wrong um she is cute
would love to do stuff with her I prefer
her with the disease that she has though
in the show I think she looks much
hotter that way yeah it's gonna be a
pretty freaky movie I mean something
tells me like that it's one of those
movies where like the trailer is really
scary but the movie itself isn't going
to be but who knows I could be wrong
it's just a trailer after all anyway
guys thanks for recommending that show
to me if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe right here it's a good
button allows you to click it and then
being subscribed you get an email
notification every time one of our bids
are up and it's really annoying
actually especially because we post like
three videos a day so yeah yeah get
ready to get annoyed if you're new to
the channel this one I like to give
shout outs of subscribers I want to give
a shout out to Lego guy 2017 shout out
equals awesome I am learning so much
from Ryan there's plenty of things you
can learn from Ryan Ryan is what you'd
call a mentor he is a teacher amongst
people
it goes Jesus Christ there's usually a
rule of three joke here but I can't
think of another teacher for some reason
so it goes Ryan Wright next
so Lego guy Legos are cool I like going
to the Lego store with no money and
being like [ __ ] I wish I could buy this
[ __ ] I'm so broke but Legos are awesome
I play with them a little bit when I was
growing up I think I had Star Wars Legos
and the lego movie that's one of my
favorite movies of the year
yeah you're a good guy you're a good guy
what's happening in 2017 exactly why why
what's up with that year you turn 18
that year and finally go to a strip club
get a lap dance maybe one of them will
be a hooker as well get [ __ ] that not in
2017 my friend Guney B's you want 100 %
Ryan I'll give you 100 % give me a
[ __ ] shoutout you cool son of a
[ __ ] you Guney B's that is a commitment
to the request of a shout-out you my
friend have earned a special place in
this heart I'm not crying of swallowing
something Jesus what the [ __ ] anyway you
should be sorry to [ __ ] up your shout
out man um I just wanted to say thank
you for that you know your level of
commitment is something that I want from
a woman one day someone who will let her
heart down and just spend the rest of
her life with me
and allow me to sleep with other woman
so thank you for being an example of
that angel Velez Cruz hey guys really
like the channel you make me laugh even
on my [ __ ] days so when you [ __ ] you
left good please keep it up and you know
I got to ask for one a shout-out for me
watch it from the east coast and J New
Jersey how you doin you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's my Boston and my New Jersey they
sound exactly the same dude I'm glad we
can make you laugh during your shitty
days honestly hearing comments like that
is what makes this really rewarding
because I have shitty days too man trust
me I mean [ __ ] its YouTube so most of
you guys are incredible human beings who
say the nicest stuff but there's a lot
of [ __ ] out there who don't show
their face in their thumbnail don't give
the real name away so they can be
[ __ ] dicks and so a lot of people
insult me all the time and you know
you're kind of used to it but there
every once in a while it does bring me
down so then I gotta watch some videos
usually a youtuber or Conan who has his
own YouTube channel and that [ __ ] picks
up my day so to know that we can do that
for other people out there makes me feel
really good
I'm going to end this video honest
sincere note